i i've hired people and uh i'll tell you
the story
i'll give a story from a buddy of mine
he started a company he was doing social
media management
he made some posts on the internet
looking for some you know people to help
me run these these social media websites
for clients
must have a college degree well the
people with college degree
with college degrees have salary
requirements so we hired him he said
that he would get his phone be ringing
off the hook from people with problems
hey i got a problem they they posted
this hey i got a problem the company
wants this what do i do what do i do
what do i do eventually said if you
can't do the job then i need to find
someone else so he fires him
puts another post up needs needs
somebody who knows social media can
can run marketing must have a college
degree what is what happens
same thing phone call after phone call
after phone call well now he's out of
money
he spent a bunch of money training these
people he wasn't getting output so he
just said
looking for people who know social media
10 bucks an hour
he gets a couple people who had moved
from middle america to california to
find
their dream in acting and he says he
says here's the job go for it
not a single phone call now he's worried
uh-oh
something must be going wrong because
they're not telling me anything he comes
back
everything okay it's all a good bus and
he was like no problems no problems
well there was this one thing from one
of these restaurants but we took care of
it
and so what he said was these young
people that moved
from the middle of the country to
california of their own volition with no
college with no education
took the initiative it wasn't the
college degree it was that they knew
they were confident in themselves to
figure out and solve this problem
whereas the people who went to college
with people who did what they were told
by their parents
and now they're you know 24 with no
experience in the real world and they're
panicking because they don't have to
solve these problems and they're asking
you to solve it for them why
the kids who went to college would
always go to their professor or their
teacher and say what do i do now yeah
and so what i see happening in this
country is a lot of that from college
people who are indoctrinated into saying
not
even the college level it's happening
down in high schools and middle schools
and this is one of the things i don't
like about this standardized
testing because what standardized
testing is doing
is is creating robotic thinking you know
you we have to teach you to be able to
pass a test we're not teaching you to
have critical thinking skills
to be an independent thinker and then of
course we
you know you need to go to college and
if we make college free then everyone
goes to college and then what happens
to the productivity of people that's
exactly what happens
one of the things that i would always
talk about when i was in the military i
want a person i want a soldier
that's a fire and forget weapon system
that's what you're talking about
it's a fire and forget weapon system so
it's same as when you
take that that uh that pistol or that
rifle you pull the trigger
as long as you have aimed it in the
right place the bullet is going to hit
the target
and so that's the type of people that we
should be trying to develop
or fire and forget weapon system
individuals that understand critical
thinking that understand
independent thought and we're rewarding
them for being independent
thinkers but what progressivism
socialism statism communism
marxism whatever you want to call it
what it is creating is a collective
group think you know when i came in here
you had star trek the next generation
love it star trek the next generation
remember the borg
oh yeah okay what was the board the
board was a collective body
no individuality whatsoever what did the
borg say resistance
is futile you will you are what what is
it
you will similarly simulate you know
your technology and your culture will be
assimilated that's it resistance is fair
and that's
exactly what we see happening young
people is that you have this collective
mentality and mindset that does not want
you to be a fire and forget weapons
system
it wants you to be part of a council
culture it wants you to be part of a
social justice
warrior you know clan or whatever you
know
you've got to be able to go out and
think and do and and be able to survive
on your own
instead of sitting around for the
authoritarians
to say that we're going to give you some
free health care we're going to give you
some free college education what's fire
forget
that's like you shoot and you just you
just accept it's done
that's exactly what he said hiring
someone that you tell them here's your
task and purpose
and they got it they don't call me back
they don't come back and keep bugging
you
you ever read the same message to garcia
it's a little short pamphlet read the
the little message to garcia there was a
a gentleman by the name
the gentleman in the military that was
chosen to to deliver a message to a
a cuban fighter named garcia where's
garcia
you just got to find him what does
garcia look like you'll figure it out
and the guy took the message and he
found garcia and you know that's what we
want and unit of acts i've experienced
when i hire
i've hired college grads i've been told
you have to tell me what to do
no joke no joke i hired someone once and
they were like what do i i hired them
for a specific job
administrative role and then i remember
one day one day they came to me and said
i don't know how to do this what am i
supposed to do and i was like if i knew
how to do it i would not have hired
you to do it so listen you've got all
the time in the world figure it out
reasonably i expect you to figure it out
quickly but i understand
this like you you go to school for
certain things i understand you can
learn
this specific program was not something
you learned in college but you can spend
the day figuring out the software they
couldn't do it
yeah they just said just tell me how to
do it i don't know how to do it either
and that's why you know back when i was
growing up the old folks down south
they used to say that boy got a whole
lot of book learning he ain't got no
common sense
and that's what they were talking about
the difference between knowledge and
wisdom absolutely
absolutely and so if there's a threat
that i see
for us as a country is getting back to
that sense of
rugged individualism and getting back to
that sense of
i can and not sitting around and waiting
for someone to tell me
what you know what to do because that
collective mentality
will always destroy yeah i feel like we
need like an emergency
to whip people into that frenzy of do it
that's why y'all are here yeah that's
why y'all are here and that's what y'all
are doing that's what y'all are
professing that's why i was
look i am so humble that you guys would
you know
ask me to come up with a gun look
look this is this is awesome because you
know again this is that
logan's run moment when you find the old
guy out there in the sanctuary and you
bring him back to the to the young city
and they impart all of this wisdom tell
you man i want to start a new political
movement
party whatever i don't care about party
politics but i want to involve the
brightest minds
do a popular win like it's just his
popularity contest at this point make
tim president i'll be the vice president
advise us and maybe i don't want to do
it but i feel like it has to happen you
guys can make me secretary of defense
let's do it yes
yes i know some people we could bring on
never going to be a president or a
politician
i don't maybe we don't need a president
a better system
but this is the movement that you all
created because you are
a bright and shiny light like it says in
the bible in matthew chapter five you're
the shining city that sits upon a hill
you're you're that you're that light
that sits on the lampstand
that you cannot put a cover over and you
guys have got to continue to get this
message out here
because that's my concern remember what
i said there was once upon a time when i
could sit down with my parents
and watch the grammys i can't do that
there is no way that i my daughters are
27-24 there was no way i would have sat
with my mother that would have been
really awkward
it was just totally
some of these super bowl uh halftime
shows i don't watch it with them
yeah i couldn't i couldn't watch it
alone well so here's here's the
important to watch the grammy's a really
good uh uh i mean issue to bring up in
that
our culture is completely fragmented and
divided you know you're you're here
saying
this is the message we got the message
out and i and i think about some of the
things that we've talked about in terms
of the armed forces and
especially in terms of the transgender
issue and i mean those are extremely
divisive topics
where you you even challenge some of
these orthodoxies on the left
and they get violent there are certain
things sure where we've seen people on
the right
get violent no answer that's right yeah
my dad used to say a hit dog will holler
yeah yeah i think it's the uh
when people can't find a logical course
of action they they
become angry right but if you're giving
it the spurs and it has
a place to go it's not going to scream
it's just going to go but my concern is
when you look to the grammys when you
look to the establishment the the major
marketing companies the social media
companies
they're the borg they're the ones who
are saying assimilate or else
yeah and and many of these people that
we used to see on youtube we did
we did a members-only segment the other
day about this the anti-sjw was we
called them
some of them have just capitulated and
given in and now they won't necessarily
agree with everything from the look
establishment but they're certainly no
longer critical of the establishment
they like shifted gears
and now they go for soft targets because
they're scared they're scared the
machine will come for them we'll destroy
them
if if we don't have people who are
willing to stand up and be on the front
line
there are more of us than there are them
and i truly believe that
and and one thing that my mom taught me
was that a man must stand for something
or else he'll fall for anything
and so to those people that are running
away from their
you know fundamental principles and
values you know you can never
acquiesce compromise appease or
negotiate enough
with the the far left with with these
the the
the woke council culture there's there's
nothing that you can give to them
which will ever satiate their appetite
for more control and more power
so at some point in time you're going to
have to make a stand
at some point in time you're going to
have to say enough i mean
pepe le pew speedy
joe biden is a bigger abuser than pepe
le pew was
like you you can see the videos of joe
biden grabbing the women what's your
name
uh tara reid i mean that's what and
still these tables and these stories
were buried
and pepe le pew is the offensive thing
but cardi b
is not listen listen pepe le pew was
prancing around saying mon sherry
or whatever yeah i learned a little
french from pepe
no no but look if you want to criticize
old art or old cultural tropes
i got no problem with that there are a
lot of things from the 20s we don't we
don't show these days
30s 40s 50s that that's fine by me but
don't come out with this cardb stuff
which again i also honestly don't care
about i won't watch it you want to do
that you can do it i'll be somewhere
else
yeah but listen how are you going to
show that and then claim pepe le pew is
the more
you know the bad thing i don't know
that's a good question
well you know where i think it's going
to come from when you look at comedians
out there like
jerry seinfeld and others that are
saying that this has gone too far i mean
mel brooks and and and the movie blazing
saddles
you couldn't show blades and saddles i
love that was the first r-rated movie i
was allowed to watch
but my dad let me watch that one yeah
because it was so good it was just
hilarious what a good i mean how long
how long until quentin tarantino gets
gets banned i mean come on that dude
uses racial slurs every chance he gets
it's it's in his movies well in the
context it depends on if he bows down to
the goddess
of the left i don't think he will well
no i don't like it but maybe a lot of
them do a lot of them do
so but but think about it sarah
silverman has come out and said this is
too much
well she got bill maher yeah bill maher
has come out and you start listening to
some of the things that he's saying
you know it's cool i like i i like bill
maher um i think he's got trump
derangement syndrome and and he spent
he's too wrapped up in you let me stop
there
it's the blue pill and the red pill
people think red pill means you're a
republican it doesn't it means you've
recognized the narrative from the media
is you know often
complete bs bill maher still believes
too much of it
but it's like he's in that you know
blue-pilled room looking out the window
and kind of seeing
the freedom and recognizing the problem
but he doesn't break through it takes
him a long time
yeah and eventually he will come around
because
again there is no trump boogeyman out
there
and the further further they get away
from the trump boogeyman
all of a sudden they're going to reach
out and see this ain't working well
they're trying to do tucker now
brian he's like tucker is the new trump
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you